let's go next to seth from san diego
seth welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
good morning david um
so a couple of oh well couple quick
questions don't worry so the first one
is um do you think in the election
liberals should take more pride in being
liberals because it seems like a lot of
these conservative ads have like i'm a
american first conservative i'm a
conservative i'm pro-conservative trump
conservative christian conservative yeah
you don't hear anyone of that being a
liberal yeah so you know you sometimes
do see i sometimes see in ads candidates
will say stuff like i'm a proud democrat
and i find it so stupid to be to be
perfectly frank
um okay what i do think is that listen
the country is really on our side on the
issues when you look at what is exactly
what is the view on abortion that's most
prevalent right now what's the view on
gay marriage what's the view on whether
we should tax the very rich to fund
social program the it's the views are of
the progressives the problem is because
the progressives
don't own it in the way that you're
suggesting
it becomes disaggregated where then the
voters don't realize you kind of really
agree with the progressives and then it
becomes this vicious circle where people
shy away from the labels and then the
voters are confused and then they think
oh i should vote for a republican so i i
do agree in general with with the point
you're bringing up
okay because uh i'm not sure if you're
familiar who bill maher is because
that's like my go-to
liberal right there because i feel like
he's at the very he speaks like 90
around 90 now percent of my language
there's some stuff i call them out on
which it's he's kind of stupid at times
yeah i mean bill maher you know the
thing about bill maher is he has joined
this contingent which is like the
anti-woke free speech left which is like
it's fine i agree agree with bill maher
about plenty but he's kind of fallen
into this thing of overstating the
degree to which the so-called woke left
has taken over the movement which i
think is a relatively small degree
actually
exactly like he like he exaggerates that
a lot but i was thinking because there's
you know his new roles like his rants
that he does yeah yeah it's hilarious
but there's this
you know recent one that he was talking
about the conservatives and like
you know talking about how you know they
kind of put the positive and negative in
the same ad and he's doing all that but
i was just wondering
is it do you think that
is not entirely smart because they want
to see kind of like bde you know i'm
saying big you know i'm not sure if i
can curse on here but what you're saying
large penis energy this sort of like
that yeah big it's scientist energy yeah
yeah you know that crap and so do you
think there's not a lot of that from the
left because every time whenever a
liberal is here you know the country
agrees with liberals like for example
like you know this is my own personal
opinion i'm not affiliating this with
anyone but like i'm you know currently
serving the country right now and uh
this is my own personal opinion not of
affiliating that with anything but no i
got you i i i agree with you and i think
the best person so far who has said it
in a direct way is actually gavin newsom
who in an interview recently said we
need to be playing offense not defense
we need to be ruthless etc and it
doesn't mean you have to agree with him
on policy but he
absolutely was completely correct about
what you're talking about
exactly because i was on my phone and
like oh you're on cnn you're freaking
liberal and i was like
well i don't watch fox all the time you
know just kind of say something like
that but like they look at liberals as
these naggy
you know
wussy you know [ __ ] like people but you
know and most the country agrees with
them so when you hear a conservatives
like oh i'm you know i'm a man or
whatever the case may be which honestly
masculinity is actually better than ever
which i don't know what the hell they're
talking about
but you know i'm sorry to drag this out
for so long i was just well seth you've
really said it all and it's been a
pleasure having you on i appreciate it
of course and sorry to drag it out so
long no problem you didn't get so much
david there is something from san diego
with a very powerful declaration
uh some things we agreed on and some
things that we did not thank you to
everyone i was able to speak to that
does it for calls today but there will
be more opportunities believe me folks
and then i hope to speak to you